un accidente cerebrovascular ocurre
cuando el flujo sanguíneo en parte de su
cerebro es bloqueado
después de algunos minutos las
hambrientas células cerebrales comienzan
a morir
usualmente el cerebro recibe sangre
mediante dos pares principales de
arterias
que se ramifican a través del tejido
cerebral y alimentan a sus células
cerebrales con un constante flujo de
oxígeno glucosa y nutrientes necesarios
para sus funciones
en un tipo de accidente cerebrovascular
el accidente cerebrovascular isquémico
una arteria en su cerebro se encoge o se
bloquea completamente impidiendo el
flujo sanguíneo regular
el bloqueo puede ser causado por un
coágulo de sangre también llamado un
trombo el cual se forma en una arteria
poco saludable del cerebro
la falta de flujo de sangre causa que el
tejido al que alimenta la arteria se
vuelva hambriento o isquémico
igualmente el bloqueo puede deberse a un
émbolo un coágulo de sangre que se forma
en otra parte del cuerpo
y viaja hasta el cerebro
el émbolo se alberga en una arteria
angosta y obstruye el flujo sanguíneo
el tratamiento inmediato para su
accidente cerebrovascular ayuda a
minimizar la lesión a las células
cerebrales y la muerte
si tiene un accidente cerebrovascular
isquémico
puede que se le dé medicación para
romper el coágulo que causa el derrame
cerebral
y más adelante su médico podría
recomendar cirugía como una
endarterectomía carotídea para reducir
su riesgo de tener otro accidente
cerebrovascular isquémico